well they were so fed up uh like i was
so
you know i'm a small business guy who uh
previous governor
martin o'malley had raised taxes 43
times in a row
uh and it had crushed our economy we had
lost 10 000
businesses and a 100 000 jobs and people
were fleeing the state
in all directions it was frustrating to
a lot of people and it was to me as a
small business owner and it was didn't
matter what your party affiliation was
people were were leaving and a gallup
poll came out that said 47 percent of
all marylanders wanted to leave the
state
and that was kind of the straw that
broke the camel's back for me
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report as always guys don't forget to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
click that notification bell
and joining me today is the 62nd
governor of the great state of maryland
and the author of still standing
surviving cancer riots a global pandemic
and the toxic politics that divide
america
governor larry hogan welcome to the
reuben report
well thank you dave it's really great to
be with you thanks for having me
my pleasure that is quite a title of a
book i mean you have got
that is a your title is a book unto
itself
uh right you made it all the way through
so i was impressed with that so thank
you
thank you i i've become a master of the
teleprompter but actually i thought that
that would be an interesting place to
start because uh the book is coming out
this week
and you actually made a whole bunch of
additions
to the book because of what's happening
right now so i thought that might be
the right spot for us to kick off here
yeah dave it was already
kind of a long title to begin with
because we were trying to cover a lot of
important
topics you know and i was covering you
know when i i was elected
um kind of overcame i was the biggest
upset in america in 2014 in a very blue
state i was
immediately hit with the dealing with
riots in baltimore and then
life-threatening cancer and you know a
lot of interesting stories to write
about
i really wanted to talk a little bit
it's not a heavy political read but i
wanted to talk a little bit about
you know the divisive politics today and
some of my thoughts on where we ought to
be heading
um and and we put together this book
sort of uh
you know february time frame was when we
were finished with it
and it was going to come out a little
earlier and uh and then the pandemic we
kind of put it on hold and ask the
publisher to hold it
it would only hold it until now and
they asked us if we would add so some
more current
activities because i was dealing with
this crisis and we added about five
chapters on the pandemic and i think it
makes it
kind of more interesting and i tell some
pretty straightforward stories about
what we've been dealing with
but i'm hoping people will find it
interesting yeah so
i want to go into each of the specific
topics that you break down
in the title but let's start with the
pandemic stuff
because as you just mentioned you are a
republican governor of a largely blue
state
if i'm not mistaken only two republican
governors have ever been re-elected
in in maryland in its entire history um
so maybe we should start there first
what's it like being an outsider
governor
whether it's you know a a red guy in a
blue state or a blue guy in a red state
just what's that like first before
pandemic time and then we'll talk about
that sure
yeah so i i you know i'm a lifelong
small business guy
never never held elective office until i
was elected governor
um our state was has the highest
democratic registration of any state in
america in 2014 i got elected
it was kind of a shock i mean nobody
expected me to i came from nowhere
we weren't even on the radar screen it
was kind of i was the least likely to
succeed i think nobody thought i was
going to be governor
but i pulled together a coalition of
you know all the few republicans we had
in our state along with
a bunch of independents and democrats
and i got elected
and then i'm governing in a state that's
a fairly liberal democratic state with a
legislature that's
70 percent you know democrats
in both chambers every single statewide
elected official
is a democrat i'm only a second
republican 50 years to be elected and
the
second one to be reelected in 242 years
so
it's look i think one of the things i've
learned in a situation
like that is that you've got to figure
out a way
to work with people on the other side of
the aisle and
it may be different if you're say a
republican in a red state
or you're a democrat in a blue state you
don't have to develop those
relationships and you don't have to
maybe compromise or find a way to reach
that middle ground
you know where you can all work together
so maybe out of necessity to get things
done
i had to be more pragmatic and figure
out
how do you how do you reach common sense
solutions and actually fix some problems
and
it turns out that turn that's what a lot
of people seem to want
because a lot of democrats and
republicans and independents seem to
like it and they
they reelected me and you know we seem
to be making some progress
are you telling me that people vote you
guys in to fix
problems is that is that what it's all
about i know i know
dave it sounds like a strange concept in
politics today because we don't see a
lot of that but i really do think it's
what a lot of people want i mean
you know we can talk about the
politics on the right and the left i
think most people regardless of where
they fall
on the spectrum they really do want uh
their
the people they elect to to office
regardless of which side of the aisle
they come from they just want people to
get to work and get things done and uh
and i think they're frustrated with the
political process and the fact that
they see a lot of divisiveness and
dysfunction they don't think people
people are getting the
job done you mentioned that you were a
small businessman before going into
politics
my sense is that the future of politics
probably on either side although i think
probably more on the republican side
is that the day of the long-term
politician the guy who comes up through
the system
is over and that the future will be
people who built their own businesses
who
innovated maybe we're in the tech world
that those will be the future
politicians
do you think that gave you unique uh a
unique way of looking at the world that
has been has been relevant for governing
i you know well first of all i agree
with you
i i think that is what we're going to
see it's what we should see
i mean i've for a long time uh sort of
been arguing against
career politicians who spend their
entire you know
professional lives in elective office
and it's i think it's what the founding
fathers originally had in mind you know
about
people just leaving whatever it was they
normally did and going in and
serving for a while in public service i
actually you know i'm the chair of the
national governors association
and active in the republican governors
association a lot of my colleagues
have similar uh profiles and backgrounds
not all of them
many of them are not lifelong
politicians
many of them have business backgrounds
and i think it may be a
sort of a new phenomenon but i'm not
alone in that regard and i think
maybe in the governor's races you may
send somebody off to washington
that's you know been a politician but in
when you're deciding
who the ceo or the chief executive is
going to be to run your state
uh you know they want to pick somebody
that's kind of competent and able to run
things and get things done and uh so you
see a lot of business backgrounds in the
folks that are running the states
yeah i think it's it's helped me a lot i
mean i you know i
i knew a little bit about government and
i knew some stuff about politics
but the business background you know my
whole career was about trying to
you know bring people together to get
things done and it turns out
that's actually a valuable thing to have
in government too
you know you don't say accomplishments
yeah
i mean strange nobody ever figured that
out before
do you find maryland to be a
particularly unique case these days
because of the proximity to washington
d.c where so many of the
the long-time bureaucrats and the people
that have just been in the system
forever
a ton of them live in maryland obviously
and that maybe filters a little bit of
what the political life is like there
maybe to a certain extent i mean what
big one of our largest population
centers is in metropolitan
washington but we're a pretty diverse
state you know we've got the washington
metropolitan area the baltimore
metropolitan area
but we've got you know some some pretty
dense areas we've got
you know but it's we've got suburban
areas very rural areas of our state
about 70 percent of our state
is rural um and so we're kind of a
microcosm i mean we're a we're
american miniature we have a little bit
of the same things that everybody has we
have probably a higher percentage of
federal government employees so we
actually have more people that are in
the private sector that maybe have
some kind of government contracting
affiliation but um
it may change we're made a little bit
more liberal and a little bit more
democratic leaning as a result of that
um it made it more challenging for me to
get elected but
you know we've been able to win over
some of those folks which is common
sense
what was going on there before you were
elected that uh a blue state would say
oh
yeah let's uh let's let this guy in
who's not a career politician who's
cobbling together this kind of strange
coalition
well they were uh so fed up uh like i
was so
you know i'm a small business guy who
would previous governor
martin o'malley had raised taxes 43
times in a row
and it had crushed our economy we had
lost 10 000
businesses and a 100 000 jobs and people
were fleeing the state
in all directions and was frustrating to
a lot of people and it was to me as a
small business owner and it was didn't
matter what your party affiliation was
people were were leaving and a gallup
poll came out that said 47 percent of
all marylanders wanted to leave the
state
and that was kind of the straw that
broke the camel's back for me
um we were 49th out of 50 states in
economic performance
yeah so i um i was frustrated enough to
do something crazy like say i've had
enough i'm going to run for governor
and it was the point where democrats
said you know i'm a lifelong democrat
i've never considered voting for a
republican in my life
but this guy's starting to make sense
and i focused on the economic issues and
talked about
you know we were going to cut taxes and
regulations and focus on growing our
private sector and trying to put more
people back to work and it's exactly
what we did we had the biggest economic
turnaround in america
we we we had more businesses open and
put more people to work than ever before
in the history of the state and
we got things done even with our
democratic legislature if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell